GAMES A PIECE.
LOPEZ HAD 11 REBOUNDS.
P.J. TUCKER 13 POINTS.
TERRIFIC DEFENSE.
OF COURSE GIANNIS ANTETOKOUNMPO
WITH 34 POINTS, 12 REBOUND, 3
ASSISTS.
HE'S WITH RACHEL.
>> Rachel: CONGRATULATIONS ON
THE WIN.
YOU GUYS WERE DOWN IN THE
SERIES.
ONE OF THOSE GAMES YOU LOST BY
NEARLY 40 POINTS.
WHAT DOES IT SAY ABOUT THIS TEAM
YOU'RE BACK TO EVEN?
>> SAYS A LOT.
WE COME IN EVERY NIGHT AND PUT
OURSELVES IN A POSITION TO WIN.
WE KNOW LEAVING BROOKLYN, THEY
TOOK CARE OF BUSINESS.
WE NEEDED TO TAKE CARE OF
BUSINESS AND PUT OURSELVES IN
THE POSITION TO WIN GAMES.
WE HAVE TO KEEP PLAYING TOGETHER
AND HOPEFULLY WE GO TO BROOKLYN
AND TAKE ONE.
>> Rachel: IT WAS SUCH A
PHYSICAL GAME.
THE NETS LOST ONE OF THEIR BIG
STARS KYRIE IRVING.
HE TWISTED HIS ANKLE LANDING ON
YOUR FOOT.
WHAT HAPPENED ON THAT PLAY FROM
YOUR PERSPECTIVE?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I THOUGHT HE GOT HIT IN THE
GROIN AT FIRST.
WHEN I WENT BACK TO THE LOCKER
ROOM, THEY SAID HE SPRAINED HIS
ANKLE.
I WISH HIM QUICK RECOVERY AND HE
CAN BE READY FOR GAME FIVE.
I WISH HIM THE BEST.
WE HAVE TO KEEP FOCUSING ON THE
TASK AND TRYING TO HAVE FUN AND
WIN GAMES.
>> Rachel: YOU GUYED CHANGED
SOME OF YOUR PERSONNEL.
P.J., TUCKER, WHAT IMPACT DID HE
HAVE ON THIS GAME?
>> HE'S BIG.
HE MADE THINGS TOUGH FOR K.D.
HE'S VOCAL.
HE'S A LEADER.
HE'S A FACE OF THIS
ORGANIZATION, THIS TEAM.
HE'S GOING TO KEEP HELPING US.
WE'LL DEFINITELY NEED HIM MOVING
FORWARD.
>> Rachel: WHAT ARE YOUR MAIN
KEYS GOING TO